le 10 mai 2000 ans les sénateurs ont
adopté en deuxième lecture et à
l'unanimité le projet de loi tendant à
la reconnaissance de la traite de
l'esclavagé en tant que crime contre
l'humanité cette loi est finalement
promulguée le 21 mai 2001 mettant fin à
plus de deux ans de débats législatifs
pour un projet porté par christiane
taubira alors députée de guyane la loi
taubira pour but de mettre fin à 150 ans
de silence politique sur la traite
négrière qui a coûté la vie à plusieurs
milliers de personnes dans les colonies
françaises
vingt ans après plusieurs avancées voulu
par cette loi ont eu lieu notamment sur
le sujet de la réparation politique et
mémorielles le 10 mai a été érigée comme
journée nationale de la commémoration
des mémoires de la traite négrière de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions
les programmes scolaires ont été
enrichies et une fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé et un mémorial
ont vu le jour à paris à pointe-à-pitre
n'est un grand débat reste pour
l'instant sans réponse celui de la
réparation matérielle pourtant évoqué
des l'abolition définitive de
l'esclavagé en 1848
alors que le congrès américain a adopté
le projet de loi portant le principe
d'une compensation financière pour
réparer les méfaits de l'esclavagé aux
états unis le débat est encore au point
mort dans l'hexagone ce débat est
interminable parce que le crime en soi
est irréparable que personne ne peut
ramener les vies perdues ni remboursé
les générations de travail gratuit et
puis il y à des réparations dues parce
qu'au moment de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
on n'a pas donné à ces personnes qui
étaient encore vivantes et les moyens de
vivre personne n'a de légitimité pour
esquiver le sujet de la réparation
on ne peut pas continuer à dire qu'il
n'y a pas de sujet c'est insupportable
cette dénégation emmanuel macron ne
s'est pas exprimé officiellement sur la
question préférant mettre l'accent sur
le volet mémorielle le chef de l'état a
notamment promis la création d'un
mémorial national aux tuileries pour
rendre hommage aux victimes de
l'esclavagé
ce projet qui devait voir le jour en
2021 a été retardé en raison de
dissensions sur le choix des artistes
sélectionnés